I want to talk to my guest there's a
real a real inspiration Dave Dana an
accountant and grad student in South
Carolina and an aspiring supermodel Dave
thank you for coming on the show
thank you for having me it's my pleasure
to be here
has reached out to you
thus far to encourage you on your
journey to lose weight
this week the biggest one was Arnold
Schwarzenegger who retweeted me and also
wrote a tweet thread and replied to one
of my comments giving me some lifting
tips and some tips in the gym but there
have been numerous other accounts zooby
as well as others but honestly more
touching to me and having more of an
impact on me have been my thought just
the hundreds of normal people who have
reached out on social media Instagram
Twitter and Facebook and just shared
their stories shared that how I'm
helping them which is truly humbling and
just it keeps me going it motivates me
and um you know we're all fighting those
inner demons we're all trying to get
through this crazy world and just
hearing people what they're dealing with
how I'm helping them how they're helping
me I mean I can't keep up with the DMS
so to be honest it was amazing to have
someone like Terminator reach out
um and uh you know I mean blew me away
that day I definitely didn't get much
sleep but beyond just sort of the
celebrity endorsements I've been blown
away by just the hundreds and thousands
of people who have come out of the
woodwork and out of social media and
just been incredibly supportive
especially given the you know incredibly
toxic nature of a place like Twitter or
social media in general especially
because I'm just mostly posting gym
selfies at a Planet Fitness and I don't
I don't really know what I'm doing you
know I'm not I'm not an expert I'm still
uh learning you know I have lost a lot
of weight but I've got a lot more to go
and I hadn't set foot in the gym
um you know until last year so a long
way to go and a lot to learn but it's
been incredible so far what motivated
you to say okay
today is the day or tomorrow's the day
that I'm gonna go to the gym
so last year I turned 30 years old
started thinking a little bit more about
becoming a husband one day a father
having kids and I got on my scale one
day and it gave me an error message
because it only went up to 400 pounds
and so I was over that amount and just
thinking about being a role model for my
future kids wanting to see them grow up
um just being a you know being around
for the future I didn't want to have to
have my parents bury me you know nobody
wants that and it was sort of a wake-up
call just to not not even be able to see
a number on your scale right like how
fat you have to be for this scale not to
work well over 400 right because that's
I didn't know it had a limit I just you
know it sat on the bottom that had a
limit so that was my wake-up call and
then ever since then you know I uh I
don't know what I'm doing but I've just
tried things when I didn't work tried
new things and just always kept in the
back of my mind that like this is you
know so I can be a good husband a good
father you know a good member of society
instead I can be around you know for a
long long time and I really didn't think
I could do that getting an error message
on my scale and that was that was June
of 2022 and that was my wake-up call
what do you think motivated you to
become so large I think there's a number
of factors that come together I think a
lot of it had to do with mental health
which we don't speak about enough
especially as men I think a lot of it
had to do with sort of the constant
consumerism the constant consumption of
the society we live in I think a lot of
it had to do with probably a little bit
of workaholism you know I got out of
college my career went well and I found
myself working more and more a lot more
stress a lot more anxiety but also you
know a lot more money than I've had
before not rich by any means but you
know fast food with a salary is a
dangerous combination especially in a
society that rewards constant
consumption that rewards more and more
and more and I also think we live in a
time where we have a lot of big
companies working with big government to
not necessarily be promote things that
are healthy but that may make more
taxpayers and more consumers and you
know a lot of what I've done to lose the
weight has been sort of take a step back
and try to figure out what really is
truly important you know and that's
working on not just my physical health
but working on my mental health as well
making sure I'm making time for family
for friends for Faith for Community not
just for work which reduces my stress
reduces my stress eating stepping back
from some of the constant consumption
and trying to make sure that I'm getting
outside you know engaging a little bit
more with my faith a little engaging a
little bit more with nature and that
really I think has put me in a much
stronger position mentally which then
feeds into your financial health and
your spiritual health and you know
everything else that goes along with it
and physical health of course as well
such an important point that the
consumption it's not just about the food
it's about a culture that encourages
constant consumption of everything I had
this thought it was around the beginning
of covid when no one knew what to do
with their time because we were a lot up
and I thought okay my bars are closed so
some of my cigar shops are closed some
of them were still open and speakeasies
but that's I don't want to out anybody
but I thought well hold on that's those
are my hobbies my hobby is that I go to
cigar bars and I have conversation and
you know there's a little bit more to it
than that but it's a hobby centered
around consuming something consuming the
cigar or consuming the drink and I
thought do I have hobbies
that are not about consumption yeah I
want to play music every now and again
but I realized I didn't really have very
many that were our culture seems to have
replaced hobbies and leisure activities
that don't necessarily
need to involve your buying things with
just consumption and and Society has
entirely turned away from the spiritual
life which obviously does not religious
practice does not require you to consume
things and in fact much religious
practice is aimed at at turning your
desire away from consuming things was
there a spiritual component at all in
your decision
yes definitely I grew up Jewish and I
had sort of stepped away from that I
lived here in the Deep South not a whole
lot of Jews down here so um but I wanted
to again as I got older as I thought
about one day having a family being a
husband and a father I wanted to at
least get somewhat more connected with
my faith with God with my Jewish
community and you're right a lot of
Jewish holidays and uh Jewish practices
involve dietary restrictions or even
fasting and to me it was just once I
started thinking about it remembering
how I grew up I was like actually
there's a lot of stepping back from
consumption there's a lot of abstaining
from various things that is very
important to Judaism and that wasn't
part of my life in fact gluttony and
over consumption were throughout my life
my financial life my physical life
everything was just always at the edge
always doing 110 and even extending to
things like my career or education and I
was feeling that that was going to burn
me out
um and burn me I guess right into an
early grave and I I needed to take a
step back and reevaluate some of those
things especially as I turned 30 and
couldn't even weigh myself you know the
first time I ever consciously fasted
as I was reverting to the church I I
thought there's no way I can't go a
whole day without eating you know our
bodies are made to to fast regularly
actually and but I thought how and and
by the end of the day by the end of just
one day I thought wow
I rely on a handful of pretzels or a
glass of Seltzer or whatever I rely on
these all day long not to feed any
actual physical need that I have but
just to do something with my hands to
take a break from my work to distract
myself and I think it's perfectly fine
to have affinities for products and
Brands and things like that I mean I
have I have a my favorite clothing store
you know and I have my favorite whatever
cigar brand or something but
it would seem that that becomes a big
problem when that becomes the essence of
your identity when your identity is not
grounded in God ultimately and my
religious tradition my community and my
family and only then do you start
talking about you like to shop at
whatever you know Banana Republic or
something you know but it seems like our
culture is just totally flipped that
yes instant gratifications and constant
dopamine hits you can see them from the
food we eat to social media to
everything else but there's no sense of
building something from the foundation
of taking your time of doing it
appropriately of using what had been
working in the past we've we've gotten
rid of all that and we're doing it all
now and it has to be instant it has to
be right now it has to be constant and
to me that was just felt and every
aspect of my life it was getting more
toxic and more unhealthy and I didn't I
just didn't feel like I had much left to
give if I kept down that path I needed
to I needed to turn and try something
you know radically different but yet at
the same time that radicalism was just
pretty basic normal things that my
grandparents or great-grandparents
probably would have recommended you know
without some of the technology people
are raving about genucel skin care
Jessica from Huntsville Alabama says my
skin looks so soft and clear I've seen a
reduced number of fine lines and dark
spots I found a new lifetime product
absolutely love it Jen you sell skincare
uses a one-of-a-kind proprietary flower
base developed by the founder and
pharmacist who is a great guy by the way
it's also comes along with rare
Botanical extracts and Powerful
antioxidants for skin care results that
work guaranteed I said I would not
endorse the product if I could not try
it if I were not impressed by the
product and also fellas I know sometimes
men are a little skeptical of getting
into Cosmetics too much even slightly
more men than women use genuscal and for
good reason geniusell's most popular
package is available to you today for
seventy percent off 7-0 at genucel.com
knowlesyt join millions of happy
customers who've already fallen in love
with the results Plus for a limited time
yet genu cells probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to genucel.com knowlesyt
genucel.com
knowlesyt so you've been doing this for
about a year and it's really great to
make a resolution and frankly
it's difficult but it's not all that
difficult to go to the gym for day one
and maybe even day two and possibly day
three but day four gets to be a little
bit harder has there been a time over
the course of this year when you've
thought ah all right enough of that
yeah there has after about three or four
months the first like 20 30 even 40
pounds comes off pretty fast especially
when you're up above 400 pounds
um and so but after that I hit a bit of
a plateau where just like walking on a
treadmill and like not eating fast food
wasn't enough I had to really buckle
down and do more and for those two or
three weeks where I was mostly out of
plateau that was the closest I came to
giving up
um or to just bailing on it and I did
two things there one was that was the
first time I think in years that I've
really prayed and really thought about
my faith more deeply and the second
thing was that I went to the doctor for
the first time in I don't know how long
since my mom made me as a kid and we got
my blood work done this was in September
of last year for the first time and we
saw some numbers that were not great
pre-diabetic range high blood pressure
um and uh you know cholesterol that was
a bit too high and combining me looking
Inward and upward religiously with some
like science backing it up from the
doctor saying hey these numbers aren't
good that really got me back in the gym
I go you know I wake up at 4am Monday
through Friday so I can get to the gym
by 4 30 I do it before my uh work starts
before grad school and so after that
point I have built made sure to build it
into a routine because every morning
you're not going to have the same level
level of motivation I had on day two but
once it becomes a habit once it becomes
a routine it's a lot more manageable now
and I think back to that sort of couple
weeks I won't say it was a moment it was
longer than a moment couple weeks of
weakness where you know there might have
been some unhealthy eating and I just
think about what I received in that time
of reflection and prayer and then what I
got handed to me from the doctor within
a two or three week period and that's
enough
um you know to make sure I keep going it
was sort of a reaffirmation that I had
started along the right path but you
know I need to lose 200 plus pounds
right I'm I'm at 80 right now I was at
30 or 40 back then that's I'm not even
halfway there right so I have a long way
to go and it has to be something that
becomes not just a diet or not just um
exercise but a lifestyle a habit you
know something that I can build and do
for for decades I have to ask you on on
diet sure I I have a hobby horse that I
have I I've I never bought into diet
fads in my whole life the one that got
me my wife sweet little Elisa convinced
me of this she has convinced me seed
oils are of the devil the Devil Himself
has a seed oil factory somewhere between
the seventh and eighth circles of hell
and that this has infected all of our
foods and made us all really fat and
unhealthy now I suspect that obesity
owes to many factors beyond seed oil is
probably just over consumption of
calories and a sedentary lifestyle and
all the rest but have you found that
it's not just the calories but it's
different types of food are are yes more
or less conducive to weight loss
absolutely I think every person my size
has gotten sort of like standard diet
advice for the last 30 or 40 years eat a
ton of salads do a ton of cardio track
every calorie make sure you're in a
calorie deficit and you'll lose weight
and to be fair I do think you'll lose
some weight I think you'll be miserable
and you'll fall off the wagon and you'll
gain it all back
um but I do think that getting a lot of
the sugar and refined carbs and Seed
oils out of your diet is what I have
found to work and be sustainable I don't
necessarily buy into any specific fat
Eat This Not That but I do think cutting
out General categories like so much
highly processed so much pre-packaged
you know if you're getting the food
handed you know through your car window
and they made it in less than 60 seconds
and you're eating it alone in a parking
lot on your lunch break it's probably
not something you should do regularly
right that type of stuff and I do think
that cutting back just or I mean I still
eat meat I eat red meat I eat eggs I
still eat vegetables and you know it's
both both sides of those are
controversial right I eat some fruit
sometimes but it's a lot more natural
it's a lot cleaner it's a lot more home
cooked and it's a lot less fast food
junk food pre-packaged food and I feel
like that's more what people would have
eaten you know a couple hundred years
ago and it's a sustainable way to lose
weight whereas if I buy diet food which
is like a lot of very low calorie you
know plant-based salad types of food I
will lose weight but I will also be
miserable I'll probably have some brain
fog and I'll fall off the wagon so I've
tried to find something that's
sustainable and more natural and more
healthy without going the route of I
only eat meat or I never eat meat or you
know like some of the very the very the
you know like I'm sure those work
because again you're doing like an
Extreme Elimination Diet which usually
will cause some weight loss but I'm not
sure they're sustainable for me and I am
Italian and Jewish so like this you know
there's some carbs and stuff that comes
in the food sometimes right you're not
you can't get rid of that I mean you'd
be divorcing a part of your cultural
heritage right yeah when I moved to
Nashville I've never uh really struggled
with my weight all that much you know
I've never the biggest I ever got was
because daily wire was maybe going to
make a movie and they needed me to gain
20 pounds which I did I gained 20 pounds
by eating pizza I cut my body fat in
half but then I forgot to cut so then I
was just kind of chubby for a little
while but but I did find when I moved to
Nashville
I gained 13 pounds in four months which
for me I'm just not a big guy so 13
pounds is pretty noticeable and I
thought what the heck happened why is
that and it's because I wasn't really
walking around anywhere I was you know
I'm I'm now in the southern suburb and I
was eating just biscuits and just the
fattiest southern food all the time from
all these local restaurants and
everything and my wife just started
cooking more you know once we had our
first child you know and sort of was
getting back in the groove of cooking
more and
it's not that I ate really all that much
less than I previously did it was just
much less sugar much less grease much
less processed kind of food and it all
went away and it did get me thinking
like huh maybe there is just something
in the typical American diet that kind
of makes you fat
yeah I don't count my calories I don't
count my carbs I'm not explicitly trying
to cut out seed oil but the diet I've
adopted in effect cuts out a lot of
carbs a lot of processed food probably
75 of my seed oils and for me that works
better than trying to explicitly you
know kill myself by cutting out every
gram of sugar and every drop of seed oil
or trying to log everything I eat or
drink into an app again it is it has to
work long term for me yeah and I would
prefer to find something that does that
rather than do a crash or a fad or
something that I think will work short
term and get maybe impressive three
month results but then three years down
the line I'll be back to where I was so
before I let you go for for anyone who's
watching or listening right now who
you know maybe wants to lose some weight
feels they've things have spiraled out
of control a little bit but they don't
know a damn thing about the gym
it's sort of like me I don't know I
don't know anything really at all about
the gym
day one you're there for the first time
since the Clinton administration
what do you do
I didn't do this until probably week two
but once I did it I stopped feeling that
intimidation and anxiety as I walked
into the gym because again I was walking
into the gym at over 400 pounds alone
having never stepped into one before and
what I would recommend isn't an exercise
but it's talking to someone find the
most like buff guy there and ask him
what you should do and then if the gym
offers like trainers or something like
that I would also engage with them but I
go at four or five in the morning so
they're not awake yet but I everyone in
the gym who you think is judging you and
who is and who you're intimidated by is
actually incredibly friendly from what I
found at least here in the Deep South
and Incredibly helpful and not
necessarily that all their advice is
great but getting a few basic ideas of
do this and then that try this and then
that and one other thing that I would
add a little bit more practical is take
it slow it's a marathon not a Sprint
take the weight light and just focus on
form and learning one thing at a time
rather than how much weight can I push
up for how many reps I know that's
popular with like Jim Bros online but
like I'm not there yet so just talk to
people learn from them and take it
slowly and don't be afraid to ask
questions and and real I mean I know I'm
saying it a lot but like that's really
the key to me is the people who I
thought were watching me and judging me
just wanted to help and were incredibly
supportive and gave me a lot of good
advice as long as I kept in the back of
my mind that I'm going to take it slowly
I'm going to keep the weight low and at
three or four or five hundred pounds
what's really important is that you're
getting moving for 30 to 45 minutes per
day getting your heart rate up getting
your blood pumping sweating you're going
to burn calories every time you stand up
you're lifting three 400 extra pounds
right so the weight's not that important
right now and then a couple months down
the line a year down the line you can
dial it in and specialize but you're
going to burn a couple hundred calories
just by going to the gym and being
active so the more relationships you can
build there and the more comfortable you
can feel long term that's what's been
successful for me well I love that
advice because that's the the most
intimidating thing is the gym Bros
because you just think man I'm never
going to be like that they're judging me
they're probably mocking me but one in
my experience the Jim Bros I know are
some of the friendliest people on Earth
and two you know man is a social
creature and so you're not you're not
going to do very much of anything on
your own as a little island you've
you've got to engage in the community
Avail yourself of the wisdom of your
peers and people who have been doing it
a long time and the wisdom of the ages
really really inspiring stuff man Dave
thank you for coming on where can people
find you
I appreciate that I'm on Twitter
Instagram and Facebook Davey Danna on
all of them and I'll pop up awesome
that's great I will I probably won't see
you in the gym though you've if anyone's
going to inspire me to go back to the
gym it might be you but I'll certainly
see you on Twitter thank you Dave
foreign